- [Cody] This is DAT 444.
We like the number four.
Letter D is the fourth
letter of the alphabet.
We're data geeks so we geek out over this,
but this is deep dive into
DocumentDB and it's innovation.
So what we're gonna do
here today is talk about
all the big feature releases
that we've announced
for DocumentDB in 2025.
DocumentDB is a purpose-built database
for managing your document
database workloads
at enterprise level scale.
This past year we've released
a lot of really cool features.
Serverless, our new compression ratio.
We've had improvements to
things like global failover,
global switchover,
and we're gonna tell you
about these features.
Get kind of deep in 'em.
Again, it's a 400 level course
and show you how you can
improve your workloads using
a lot of these new features on DocumenDB.
I guess we haven't really
introduced ourselves.
- No, I guess we haven't.
- I'm, I'm Cody Allen.
I'm a solution architect with the service.
With me is Vin.
- Hey everybody, my name is Vin.
I am one of the product managers
with the DocumentDB team
and I'm super excited to share,
you know, what we've launched this year.
- Awesome, so we're gonna start off,
we're gonna talk about the architecture.
Before I start,
who's never been to re:Invent before?
This is your first year here?
Dude, this is awesome.
We had a session earlier and
like 80% of the attendees
were brand new, so that's awesome.
I'm glad that you're here.
Anybody been here for like five times,
six times, seven times?
Man, that's awesome.
I don't know how many years
re:Invent's been going on,
but five, six years in a row is awesome.
The reason I ask that is because
we have names and numbers for sessions.
This one's DAT 444.
DAT means it's a database session 444.
Pick any one of them.
That just means it's an expert level.
So an expert level session means that
we kind of expect you to know a little bit
about DocumentDB.
You've probably been hands-on with it.
You're using it in a
production environment.
What that means is we're gonna
skip over the basic stuff.
We're gonna go straight
into the kind of expert level materials,
but we are gonna start
off with the architecture.
I want to set a foundation for us
because DocumentDB was purpose built
and one of the key features
of it is its architecture.
So we're gonna spend some time on that
and we're gonna get into the fun stuff.
We're gonna go over those things
like enhanced compression,
Serverless, Graviton4.
We were so excited about Graviton4,
we skipped Graviton3.
We came out with DocumentDB 8.0.
Again, we just skipped six and seven
and went straight to eight.
And we're gonna talk
about New Query Planner,
one of the new features that you get
with a DocumentDB 8.0.
But like I said, 400 level session,
we're gonna skip over the marketing slide.
We're not gonna spend
time on the fluffy stuff
that you can read on our webpage.
We don't have a need for it.
You know what you're top...
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, that was not supposed to be there.
Sorry.
So we're gonna skip over
the marketing slide.
Sometimes you'll see
like the NASCAR slides,
you know, some, they'll say,
"Oh, look at Aurora and look
at all of its customers.
We have to justify ourselves."
And they'll segment out
their customers by saying,
"Oh look, we have customers here
in the marketing department."
Like we need to just...
Oh, son of a...
So ignoring that,
we're not gonna talk
about that kind of stuff.
Help me baby Jesus.
There we go, cool.
Architecture, let's jump right into it.
Now DocumentDB is a purpose-built database
and the main feature here
is a separation of compute and storage.
The reason we did this
is so that you could scale your workloads
based on the resources that you need,
either that compute
layer, that storage layer,
and that storage layer
is actually broken up
into two different pieces.
We have the distributed storage
volume that holds your data
and we have your backups that go to S3.
We'll dive deep into that
here in a little bit.
Your data is automatically
replicated six times
across three availability zones.
That means you're in multiple
physical data centers
and that gives you that
enterprise grade durability.
What's really cool about this durability
is you get six copies of it
even if you have a
single compute instance.
It's not dependent on how many
compute instances you have.
You can even run headless.
You can run with no DocumentDB
instances whatsoever.
And so six copies of your data.
Now can't interact with it
'cause you do have to
have a compute instance
to actually query your data,
but you could do that.
Because this data durability
is handled at that storage layer.
Again, you don't have to worry
about that compute layer at all.
We scale up to 128
terabytes of data for you.
You don't have to worry about it.
And that means that you're not gonna hit
any kind of compute
layer size restrictions.
In some database systems
because the compute and
storage is co-located together,
if you hit a certain amount
of storage that you're using
in order to get more storage,
you have to scale up,
you have to add more vCPU to it.
You have to add more RAM.
DocumentDB, you scale independently.
You don't have to do this.
This also eliminates the need
to do things like sharding
where you have to split your data
up into certain segments
on different clusters.
Now all of this is gonna reduce
that operational overhead.
It's gonna reduce the risk
of having data hotspots.
And because your data is replicated...
Has six copies across
three availability zones
no matter how many instances you have,
no matter what size you have,
it means that it's gonna grow with you,
it's gonna grow with your workload.
Document database has no SQL...
Most legacy systems were
built on relational databases.
Microsoft SQL Server, Oracle.
Any relational DBAs,
database folks in here?
My people, I love you.
You're gonna love what we
show a little bit later.
Document databases are
still kind of greenfield,
they're still net new.
You do see some migrations to it,
but it's really a developer's database.
So you're building from scratch
and when you do that,
you don't really care about durability
or availability, right?
You just wanna develop something
to see if it's gonna work,
and that quickly grows, right?
As you have success for it,
it's gonna build up.
We all know about the server
under the developer's desk
that's running a production system
because they developed
it, it looked great,
they sold it to leadership
and now it's sitting
under their desk still.
That's...
It just kind of hides it in the shadow.
With DocumentDB,
you get this no matter what size instance
you have as you scale up.
So you're gonna have that
enterprise level durability
and availability and security
from start to finish.
Now the data in DocumentDB
is log structured.
Most traditional databases,
you use a block storage device.
This is designed around
database interaction.
So that means that it doesn't
have to concern itself
with that underlying
storage layer whatsoever.
Data is gonna continuously stream to S3.
Most database systems,
you have to do a...
You know, I'm gonna take this
back to our SQL server days.
You have to do your full backup
and then you have to do
your incremental backups.
That all runs in the compute layer, right?
We have to use compute layer resources
in order to do those backups.
But because of the log
structure of DocumentDB
and because we stream this
from the distributed storage volume,
that happens outside of the critical path.
That means that your
applications are not affected
by any of these backups whatsoever.
It all happens seamlessly
for you behind the scenes.
These blocks of data that we store in,
these are called...
These are about 10 gigs in size
and this is called a protection group.
These are the things that
get replicated across 10
or across six different AZs.
This is why your storage
grows in 10 gigabyte chunks,
and this is why the minimum you charge
for storage is 10 gigabytes
because that's the smallest block of data
that we have in DocumentDB.
Now this storage device...
The storage layer is designed
around handling failures.
It can lose an entire availability zone
and a block of data in another AZ
and still be accessible.
We have a core model,
that means that in order
to have a successful write,
we have waited for an acknowledgement
of four out of those six blocks.
And when we...
So basically your
application sends a write,
we write to four blocks.
As soon as four blocks
have acknowledged it,
we tell the application you're good to go.
We have the data and at the same time,
we write those last two blocks to give you
those six copies of data.
Now for reads,
we're just looking for
three outta the six blocks,
which is what you see here.
And honestly, for recovery
purposes for reading,
we're really just looking for
one healthy node to come back
and give us that data back.
Now in this situation,
we have that worst case scenario,
that failure situation.
And guess what?
The database is still available
because of this core model.
The storage volume has a
self-healing architecture.
That means that if a block is down,
it's failed or it's
gone under maintenance,
whatever, it's not available,
the storage nodes actually
use a peer-to-peer
gossip protocol where they're
able to talk to each other
and rebalance that data among themselves
while it's getting those
other data blocks back.
Other cool thing about this is
traditional database systems.
If you have 10 terabytes of data
and that node goes down,
you're recovering 10 terabytes of data.
That can take a minute or two, right?
That might take a second to get that back.
Our storage blocks are 10 gigs,
so the meantime to
recovery is much faster.
It takes a lot less time to
restore that 10 gigs of data,
all of this without having to do anything.
This is all handled
for you in the backend.
Last thing I wanna talk about
is the checkpoint processes.
Databases use a regular
checkpointing process
and nearly all of them,
it's a single threaded process.
The writer writes block
after block after block.
With DocumentDB,
with this attributed storage model,
we can actually make these in parallel
and we can also recover in parallel
and that makes that recovery process
a whole lot faster than most
traditional database systems.
Now you would think that, again,
like traditional database systems that
readers would have to go all the way
back to that distributed storage volume
to get new data as data's updated
and that would make reading slower.
But again, with DocumentDB,
what we've designed is we send updates
to distributed storage volume
and then we send 'em directly
to the reader instances
via write ahead logs.
So readers will look at those changes
and if they have 'em in their storage,
they apply 'em.
If not, they ignore 'em.
In other words,
if I have a document
that says Cody's favorite color is purple
and I do an update,
well, that update goes
to the writer instance.
The writer gets it and says,
"Okay, Cody's favorite color is now red.
I'm gonna write that in storage volume."
The writer's then gonna
tell the secondary,
he's gonna say,
"Hey, I have an update to Cody's document.
If you have that memory, update it."
The reader instance is
gonna look at it and says,
"Yes, I have that.
I'm gonna update my information
that I have in my cache."
If it doesn't just throws it away,
it ignores it, right?
That's gonna lower your
replication lag as well.
But it also shows you that
we don't dirty the cache
of reader instances from the primaries.
We keep these caches completely
separate from each other.
So now that we have a background
done in our architecture,
let's talk about these features.
And the first one I wanna talk about
is this enhanced compression.
Two years ago,
I think it was two years ago,
we released LZ4
compression with DocumentDB
and this made a pretty significant impact
for your storage volume
'cause we didn't have any
compression before that.
This was the first kind of
compression that we released out.
This year we've released
Zstandard dictionary compression
and this is a very
significant step forward
with the storage savings
you can see with DocumentDB.
Now with LZ4,
the biggest gains were
with large documents.
The larger the object is,
the better it compresses.
But with Zstandard,
we're seeing significant gains
even in smaller documents.
LZ4 has to analyze each
document independently.
It doesn't look at a
broad range of documents.
It looks at each one
that it's coming across.
LZ4 or with Zstandard,
we're pre analyzing common field patterns
and this is a dictionary of these.
So we're seeing highly
efficient compression
when you have repeated fill
names, repeated schemas,
and this all translates
to significant storage,
cost decreases,
a couple other performance increases
that we'll talk about in a second.
All right, that's the marketing slide.
What does this mean?
What does this look like?
So here we have a sample schema, right?
Dictionary compression
is going to replace
frequently occurring values
with references to a dictionary.
So in this example,
we have these very
verbose field names like
customer_identification_number
and product_description_text, right?
These were really long.
I'm gonna pause here for a second
because I wanna take a segue
before we go down the compression route.
Does anybody see an issue with...
Well, maybe issue is not the right word.
Does anybody see an anti-pattern here?
Or maybe something that we can improve
even without compression?
What could we do with this?
JSON is great.
JSON data model is fantastic
because it's very easy to parse.
It's human readable.
We can all look at this and
determine what it's doing,
what the data is, right?
It's very helpful.
But you have to remember
that we're taking up a lot of extra space
with these verbose names, right?
Every single character
that we have in here
is more bytes that we're
adding to our document.
Simplifying field names
can save us a ton of space.
So for example, if we shorten these,
we made customer_identification_number,
cust_id.
We're saving 23 bytes per document
just in shortening that field name.
Product_description_text,
we shortened that to four bytes, right?
We just saved 20 bytes
per document, right?
Imagine you had a
relatively small collection
of about 10 million of these documents.
We do the same thing for every
single one of those fields.
Guess what?
We just saved 60% of our storage
on that document by using
shorter field names.
We haven't even brought
compression into this, right?
We're just saying shorten
those field names.
Something to keep in mind, right?
If you go back and look at your documents,
think about this,
look at your field names.
They don't have to be verbose.
It's good that they're human readable,
but you and I are not reading at the speed
and frequency that most of our workloads
are running through.
All right, so that being said,
this is showing you what that looks like.
So the dictionary compressions
are gonna go through
and it's gonna create a mapping
of those common field names
and it's gonna replace them.
Now the data that's stored in
DocumentDB when you use this,
is storing the references.
It's not storing the full field,
it's storing just the references to that.
Essentially it's building this very
sophisticated dictionary
by analyzing this large sample set.
You have to have at least a 1000 documents
before it kicks in.
So as soon as you turn it on,
until you get to that 1000 documents,
you're not gonna have that dictionary
and then it'll create it.
It's going to...
You know, with...
When you have millions of documents,
it's gonna see that customer
identification number occurs
in predictable positions,
in predictable context,
and it's gonna create a more
efficient coating standard
because of that.
We did some tests.
We'll start off with red,
because red is negative,
red means bad, right?
What we see in red is the CPU usage
or CPU utilization when we
turn on Z standard compression,
it went up by about 17%.
It went up from 59% to 69%.
Well, clearly compression
isn't free, right?
That CPU represents that
computational cost of compressing
and decompressing those documents.
Next, the obvious impact
here is the blue line, right?
Even versus LZ4,
the amount of storage
that we're keeping on disk
with this compression
is significantly lower.
We dropped from about three
40 gigs down to 125 gigs.
And then finally what we see in red,
purple, pink, I don't know,
it's kind of a weird color.
The same color as your
headphones, I think.
We saw that write throughput went down,
from 142 megabits to 85.
But what's cool here is it went down
and our operations increased.
So we were able to increase from 92,000
inserts per second to
143,000 inserts per second
while lowering this throughput.
So you're getting
improvements across the board.
We also wanted to test how this worked
with different schemas, right?
I told you that LZ4 is
great with big documents.
Zstandard is great in small documents.
So we started off with
the GitHub user database.
This is a publicly available data set
and documents here are
about one kilobytes in size
and when we use Zstandard over LZ4,
we saw a greater than 3x
improvement in compression ratio.
We also created our own retail schema
of about two kilobyte documents
and we saw about a 2x increase
in that compression ratio.
At the very end,
we have this large metadata,
13 megabyte documents and
we saw a compression ratio
go from about 18 to one
with LZ4 to 147 to one.
Imagine that,
your 13 megabyte document just
went down to 90 kilobytes.
That's a very substantial decrease.
What's cool about that very last graph,
that last example,
that's not a test.
That is a production
customer that did that.
When we released that,
they applied this to their workload
and they were able to
see an 8x increase...
Not from uncompressed versus LZ4.
Now at enterprise scale,
we'll talk about the CPU again.
the negative part, right,
I wanna focus on that.
But at enterprise scale,
storage cost often exceed the CPU cost
of slightly slower compression.
So for example,
a 40% compression ratio can translate into
pretty substantial cost reductions
for what you're paying for storage.
Beyond direct storage cost,
compression reduces your I/O operation,
it lowers your backup footprint
and it even decreases your
network bandwidth usage.
Compressed documents require
fewer I/O operations.
This is because more logical data
fits within each physical I/O operation.
Compressed document gives you better
cache utilization, right?
Because you can fit more of
these documents in cache.
We keep documents compressed
on storage over the wire
and in your cache on
those compute instances.
So what that means is that might decrease
the need for your compute instance size.
So that gives you additional cost savings
through cost optimizations.
Here we're just seeing
what the cost difference is
because that's the physical thing.
Now everything else that
we're talking about,
your cache, your compute size,
that depends on your workload.
Here I wanna kind of stretch
your minds a little bit.
I wanna think about this as a
multidimensional improvement.
A couple years ago we
released I/O optimized storage
for our customers that have very busy,
very heavy I/O heavy workloads
and this was really marketed
as a cost improvement, right?
It allowed you to stop paying for I/O
and basically get it for free.
But the trade off is you're
paying more for storage,
but behind the scenes there's actually
a lot of performance increases, right?
Throughput increases and
latency decreases for that.
We won't go into that too much here,
but you get cost benefits
and performance benefits.
Now the trade off,
what is a trade off here?
You don't pay for I/O anymore,
but you do pay three
times more for storage.
So you're paying, as of right now,
U.S. East-1, you're paying
10 cents per gigabyte
per month with standard.
With I/O optimize, you're paying 30 cents.
So three times more.
In this example,
with LZ4, we were at 1.7
terabytes compressed,
but with Zstandard we went
down to 500 gigabytes.
What that means is that
our inflection point
for where I/O optimize can make sense
goes down significantly.
So our break even point for standard
was about 1.7 billion
operations per month,
about 660 operations per second.
Once we use Zstandard,
that inflection point lowered
to about 500 million operations per month
or about 193 operations per second.
So you don't have to have
this massive enterprise scale
to start recognizing these cost savings
when you start combining these.
Zstandard allows you to combine
with other DocumentDB features
and really multiply your savings
and possibly even
multiply your performance.
Where do you use it?
Where does this work best?
Well, dictionary
compression is really good
when you have repetitive field names
and repetitive structured elements.
Collections that have deeply nested fields
with consistent schemas,
standardized schemas.
They're gonna get the
best outta this, right?
Because they have field names
that are in a predictable spot
and they can make the...
The dictionary can help that.
However, the other side of this,
if you have a lot of documents
that have variable schemas,
very sparse schemas or
highly variable structures,
well, you're only gonna
see modest improvements.
You're still gonna see improvement,
but not nearly as much as if
you had standardized schema.
Compression is usually
better with larger documents.
That's it.
400 level session expert,
that's what you learn.
Compression works with big things.
That's it, thank you, goodnight.
No, I'm kidding.
Compression works great
on big objects but,
and that's where LZ4 focus.
Zstandard works with those big documents.
We saw it with a 13 megabyte documents,
but also in the smaller documents.
Read heavy workloads
generally are gonna
benefit more from Zstandard
than write heavy just because
there's less I/O bandwidth
and we can process those a
lot more efficiently in cache.
Things like high frequency point queries
are gonna have an improved latency.
But on the other side,
if you're doing large range queries
that are returning multiple documents,
you might see a performance decrease
and that's because of
that overhead, right?
That compression and decompression
overhead we saw earlier.
For write operations,
simple inserts benefit from this
again because of those
lower I/O operations.
However, if you are doing any
kind of complex operations
where you're doing
multiple writes at once,
there's a lot more compression
that has to happen.
Higher CPU usage.
Oh, and we have pretty
pictures to go with it.
All right, next Graviton4 instances.
Is anybody using Graviton4
instance in DocumentDB yet?
You started to raise your hand.
You want to.
You were like right there.
Okay, not with DocDB, gotcha.
So Graviton...
Stepping away from DocumentDB,
Graviton is unique to AWS, right?
It was really designed
to give you the best price
performance for cloud workloads.
Graviton instances are really good at CPU
intensive workloads.
They're really good for
memory intensive workloads,
like databases.
So it really makes sense.
When we released Graviton2
instances in DocumentDB,
we saw a 30% price performance increase.
Each Graviton instance that
we released from two to three
and now to four brings pretty
significant performance gains
and this fourth generation is
seeing 30% performance gains
over Graviton3,
not Graviton2 but Graviton3.
So similar to when we released Graviton2,
we're seeing pretty
significant performance impact
to workloads and cost
benefits from using these.
Well, what does that look like?
So we looked at it from an in-memory
versus out of memory workload to see
what kind of performance
impact we could have.
Clearly in-memory workloads
are gonna benefit significantly from this.
We're seeing over a 100% price performance
increase in read workloads
and update workloads, 136%.
Even for those workloads
that are out of memory
where things don't fit in cache,
you're still seeing a significant increase
in your performance there.
Now there is a price difference.
We started off with R5 instances...
We actually started off with R4.
We'll ignore...
So ignore those.
We started off with R5,
we released Graviton2, r6g,
and we lowered the cost by 5%.
So what was cool is
even if I did nothing except
change my R5 instances to r6g,
I saved money in my performance increase,
it was dead simple.
It made sense.
With r8g,
you're seeing a 5% increase.
So essentially if you're
going from R5 to R8,
there's no difference.
It's staying the same.
It went down, it went up.
Despite the cost increase though,
we can see a performance
increase that far exceeds
that price premium that
you're paying for these.
Performance gains are consistent
across all instant sizes,
whether it's extra large
up to 16x, extra large.
But what you're seeing here
is this performance benefit
by switching over to these.
Next, Serverless.
So no r8g users.
Anybody using DocumentDB
Serverless currently
or tried it out?
Oh man, y'all have so much
to do when you get back.
You need to try out Serverless.
But to talk about this,
I'm gonna hand things over to Vin
and he's gonna walk us through that.
- All right, thanks, Cody.
Really awesome.
Actually some of those things that
Cody shared just earlier
about the performance benefits
of r8g, we actually...
When we launched it,
we actually already had a
few customers come to me.
I actually met some of
'em earlier today about
how all they had to do was switch over
from an r6g to r8g.
There was no functional changes
and they just got better price.
In fact, some of them
were able to actually
scale down their instance.
So there's a cost...
You know, indirect cost
savings there as well.
All right, so you know for those
who have missed the first few minutes,
I just saw a few folks coming in later.
My name is Vin,
I'm one of the product
managers with DocumentDB.
Again, and we're gonna
dive right into Serverless
where I'm gonna provide a short overview
and we're going to dive into
some of the inner workings
of how we made Serverless
work for DocumentDB.
So the core concept of Serverless
is that the system scales
with your workload requirements, right?
So as compared to a traditional system
where you could either,
A, under provision,
which causes some challenges
if you have a peak.
So there might cause some
application challenges there
if it goes over your system requirements.
It would cause some challenges.
Or you could overprovision
again, this is gonna cause
some other types of challenges
in terms of being inefficient
use of your resources.
Now in between this you
could manually alter
and change the way...
Change your resources as you go.
However, that is an extra step for you.
The core idea is that
Serverless really scales
with your workload needs
and this is exactly what
Serverless in DocumentDB does.
So in August we launched
DocumentDB Serverless.
So if you haven't tried
it, I don't blame you,
it was just right before the holidays
and it was at the end of summer.
Maybe y'all were coming
back from your vacation.
So the idea is that if
you have larger workloads,
the instance will scale
up to meet the needs
of your instance...
Meet the needs of your workload.
And it could scale anywhere
from as less than one CPU
with two gigs of memory
all the way to 64 CPUs
with 512 gigs of memory.
So anywhere in between,
in fairly granular form.
You're not making those
jumps like you do with a,
say r6g large, which has two CPUs
to an XL which has four CPUs,
which is a more discreet jump.
You can easily switch between Serverless
and provision instances.
So you can see here I
have a serverless instance
in the middle there,
it's sitting beside two other instances,
two other replicas,
which are different provision instances.
What this really enables you to do
is to adopt Serverless
without having to do any data movement
because of that benefit of separation
of compute and storage.
So whether you have a
100 terabytes of data
or 10 gigabytes of data,
the amount of time to switch from
between provisioned and serverless
is pretty much constant.
And last but not least,
we introduced a new unit
to measure database...
Serverless resources
and it's gonna be called
DocumentDB Capacity Units.
So let's talk a little
bit about that as well
because there's some
cost implications here.
Database Capacity Units,
DCU for short has...
One DCU has approximately
two gigabytes of memory,
some CPU and network resources.
And this comes in a package,
that is, we don't scale your CPU,
your memory independently.
This comes as a package
and on the right side you can see
that there's a max and minimum DCU.
When you are provisioning your cluster,
what you could do is specify
the number of max DCUs
or minimum DCUs to help
you control your cost
or provide performance guarantees.
And our system does scale in increments
as small as half a DCU.
So you're not scaling
between, I was saying...
In discreet steps of say,
you know, two vCPUs all
the way to four CPUs.
This does more incremental scaling
and we scale on many dimensions.
There's an internal
algorithm where we scale on
CPU utilization, memory pressure,
network throughput.
All these aspects will
contribute to scaling
and adding more DCUs to your system.
And the last point,
this is actually a very important point
and I'll tell you why later.
So just keep a note of
this last point here,
later in this slide I'll
be referencing this.
And also an interesting aspect
is that we don't scale linear.
That is if you have a larger database,
it will scale faster
than that of a small one.
So let's say you have a 20 DCU instance,
it's gonna be able to add 10 DCUs
faster than that of a instance
that has only one DCU as a starting point.
All right, let's get to
dive a little bit deeper
on actually some of the
implementation details.
Actually one of the key aspects
how we made Serverless work
for DocumentDB
and that is actually
one thing specifically
I wanna talk about is
buffer cache resizing.
Actually for a while now,
you could actually already today
dynamically change your resources
applied to a virtual system.
So if you're working with Cgroups in Linux
or containers which is built
on the concept of Cgroups,
you could actually change the setting
of how many CPUs and how much
memory is being applied to
your container in Kubernetes.
However, the challenge with a database
is if you just start...
If you just decide to,
"Hey look, I'm gonna just
reduce the amount of memory,"
this could cause a lot of thrashing.
That is, you may be
evicting the wrong pages
and that's gonna cause a
lot of performance issues
and it's gonna drive up I/Os as well.
So let's talk a little bit about,
you know, this diagram.
So here in the bars you see
from the pink to the red,
these represent pages
inside our buffer pool.
The darker the red,
the more frequently it is accessed
and one of the things that we follow
that we have internal algorithm of
how we sort the pages is
a combination of both least recently used
and least frequently used.
So let's say I do a lot of frequent reads
from my buffer pool, my application,
those are in the deep red.
And let's say I need to go
to disc to get some data.
So here I'm gonna go
fetch some data from disc
and notice how the way we sort it
is not in the very front,
that is, it may...
Just because we accessed it recently,
doesn't mean we access it very frequently.
So later on when we do
any resizing activities,
we may just truncate those pages
before we do more frequent ones.
More frequent ones.
All right, let's take a
look at how we shrink.
And it's pretty simple.
So for pages that haven't
been used for some time
and it is...
So based on a combination
of LRU and and LFU,
we're just gonna truncate
and drop those pages
from our buffer pool and
this is gonna enable us
to shrink our buffer pool
and resize our buffer pool.
So this is what you see when
Serverless scales back down
when you're not using that many resources.
This is how it happens.
And again, I really wanna stress that
this is a little bit of
magic here because, again,
if we evict the wrong
pages very frequently,
it's gonna drive up I/Os and
this strategy really ensures
that we're not doing some of those things
that cost performance and cost issues.
Let's go into an example here.
I wanna show you two workloads.
One, there's the workload
against a provisioned instance
and the other workload is
against a serverless instance.
The view you are seeing
here is the view we have...
A tool called performance insights.
It measures how much
load is on your instance
and that dotted line you see in the middle
is how many resources measured
its vCPUs on your instance,
your system.
And the reason why this vCPU is...
Why we choose vCPU is because, one,
if you have...
This represents approximately
how many processes do you
go around at any given time.
So you can see in this diagram that
most of the time we have about three
or four average active sessions.
That is, there are three or four queries
that want to be run at
any given time on average.
However, we only have two vCPUs,
even if we add more load to our database,
it's static.
It's not any adding any more...
It's not changing the amount of resources.
And what this means is
that I may be experiencing
additional query latency
even if my indexes are in place,
even if my date...
My queries are optimized,
my database is under provisioned.
Let's take a look at it from another view.
So we could slice this by weights
and what this tells me is
what is my process spending
a lot of its time doing?
And here notice how there's a lot of red,
depending on the color may
be brown from the back.
This is I/Os.
And what this in indicates to me is that
not only am I trying to
do three or four things
at any given time
and I only have two vCPUs,
I'm actually spending a
lot of time going to disc,
spending a lot of time going to I/O.
To me this indicates that,
"Hey, maybe I don't have enough memory,
I don't have enough memory for
the working set of my query."
So I'm actually being very inefficient
and it's gonna increase the
query latency of my workload.
Now let's take a look at the same workload
on a serverless instance.
So on the bottom there, on the bar graphs,
you see that it's about
three, that's how many...
Again, three average active sessions.
But you notice that the bar already at 16.
So what this tells me is, "Hey, look,
the system needed more resources
perhaps probably for memory, right?"
So the working,
so even though I'm only
running three processes
at any given time,
I needed 16 vCPU or
DCUs worth of resources
to run this query.
Now later on to the right,
what I did was I just
added more artificial load
just for demonstration
purposes to show you that
that vCPU line which represents
the number of resources
on my instance is not static,
it does scale as I'm adding
more load to our database.
Now I wanna show you from another view,
this is the view based on, "Wait,
what are my CPUs doing?"
Notice here that it's mostly green
and it's actually not spending
a lot of time doing I/Os
and this signals to me that,
"Hey, this is actually quite efficient."
I'm not spending a lot of time
going to disc, getting data,
bringing it back and processing it.
I'm actually spending a lot of time in CPU
which means I'm just processing this data.
So quite efficient there.
So if you haven't tried out Serverless,
highly recommend it.
It's really easy to switch
back and forth from provisioned
as well.
All right, switching
gears to DocumentDB 8.0
and the New Query Planner,
which is core of DocumentDB 8.0.
Who here heard that we
launched DocumentDB 8.0?
Very few folks.
Well, I wouldn't blame you
'cause we actually just
launched this three weeks ago,
pre re:Invent,
probably during
Thanksgiving for this thing,
before this event.
So if you missed it,
this is a very high level
recap of what's included.
A big focus this year
in terms of our latest launch
is really around performance
and I think Cody already covered
some of those aspects with compression.
But the New Query Planner is also
a very key part of the DocumentDB 8.0,
which I'm gonna go into shortly in a bit.
The last performance piece
is around vector indexes.
So you know, to future proof
you a little bit about,
you know some of those apps
that you are gonna build
on DocumentDB,
we introduced parallel index
build for vector indexes,
which provides up to 30
times faster index builds
for vector indexes.
The second piece of it is
MongoDB API compatibility.
We heard from a lot of our customers
they want to bring their MongoDB
7, 6 and 8.0 applications.
They have the drivers that
work with those versions.
You can now bring those
workloads to DocumentDB as well.
We've also introduced a
handful of new MongoDB APIs
and functions such as
Views and Collations,
that's included as well.
So if you are waiting on
some of these features
to adopt DocumentDB, we have them now.
Let's go into the New Query Planner,
which we're gonna spend the
last bit of this session on.
So starting 8.0,
we launched a New Query Planner
and this is gonna be a large
collection of improvements.
However, for the remainder of the time,
I'm only gonna show two examples
that highlight some of the things
that the New Query Planner can do.
First is improvements
around choosing an index.
So the New Query Planner
has expanded index support,
delivering performance improvements
for certain operations.
And this includes, for this example,
if you have negation operations,
we will now choose a
index over a collection.
So let's walk through
a very simple example.
I have a sample document here,
very simple one,
I'm gonna create an index on
it and then I wanna do a find.
But notice how that find
has a $nin operation
or not in operation.
Now with Query Planner 1,
now you could actually
rewrite your query to do this,
to take advantage of the index.
But the default behavior was to use...
The winning plan was to
use a collection scan.
You can see here it says COLLSCAN.
And however,
with the new query planner we
default to the winning stage
of using an index scan as noted there.
The second thing I'd like to call out
and point out to you is we also...
When you do explain plan,
we also included the planner
version as part of the output.
So if you are doing a migration
and you want to use the first...
You know, the old planner version
as you're switching over,
we allow you to switch
between planner versions
but it's highly recommended
that you use the latest one.
So that was a very simple example
where we changed a single stage
and we swapped it from
collection to scan to index scan.
But let's take a look at
a more complex example
with aggregation pipelines.
Not only do we change certain stages,
we actually have the ability to
take a look at your query as a
whole and find optimizations.
So here there's two stages
of my aggregation pipeline.
One of 'em is a lookup,
if you're familiar with SQL,
this is equivalent to a JOIN.
And unwind is pretty much an
operation that flattens out
any document that has an array in it.
So by doing...
First, what this query is gonna go do
is first do a JOIN effectively
and then flatten out all the arrays.
But with the New Query Planner,
we actually simplify this
and do a single step
and I'll show you that
through an example in a bit.
Now for those who are
unfamiliar with unwind,
I wanna show just a very simple example
of what it kinda looks like with emojis.
If your document looks something like this
and you do an unwind on the array field,
you get three documents.
So you do an unwind on
that chef emoji there,
you get three instead of one.
All right, so let's go through an example.
So let's say I have two collections,
one of them is my orders collection.
Here I have the customer name
and the product IDs of which they ordered.
And then I have a second collection
which has all the product details.
So laptop, the price, phone,
the price and so on.
Now let's say I want a set of documents
that has all the orders for
each product detail, right?
So you can see here effectively
what I'm expanding on is
the orders collection.
I want to blow that up
and I want to get a detail
of every single product,
that is being bought in the orders.
The way I would do this,
the exact same query I shown before.
First I'm gonna join these two collections
and then I'm gonna do an unwind on it,
which flattens out each
one of those arrays.
So with Planner Version 1,
and I know there's a lot going on here,
while I'm showing you on the left,
and this is for reference purposes,
this is the output of the explain plan,
but I have the tree view
equivalent on the very right.
When I am...
One thing to note is that
this nested loop lookup stage,
what I'm actually doing
is I'm actually joining
these two collections
and then I'm gonna store it in memory
so they can unwind it later.
Now this ends up to look
something like this.
Where I have order,
order number one,
and then I have two products
under product details,
order number two,
and I have multiple product details.
You can imagine that if my
array had 100s of entries
and I have lots of different
products to look under,
this object can be very, very big.
And the fact that we're
just storing it in memory
means that this intermediate step
could be very, very expensive.
Whereas Planner Version 3,
one thing that we do is that
we do not create this temporary object
and store it into memory.
Instead, if we take a look
at both of these collections,
one thing that you'll note is that
the final stages produces the documents
and how the query planner
does that is it notices that,
"Hey look, I'm trying to do an unwind
after a lookup stage."
So instead of building
that temporary structure
and then just to unwind it later,
as I'm doing the lookup for
each individual product ID,
why don't I just do the lookup
against the products collection
and stream those results as the final set.
And that's exactly what we do.
So if you compare the tree structure
of both these query plans,
one thing I like to point out is
this nested loop lookup
returned eight documents.
I know obviously I'm working with a very
small collection here,
but if you have a lot of documents,
you could think of this as almost like
O-N squared to notation of runtime.
So this stage can use up a lot of memory.
So these...
Again, these are just two
examples of the New Query Planner.
There's actually like tens of
10s and 100s of optimizations
that we're planning to go do
that you could check
on our developer docs.
These are just two to
show case what we're doing
with our New Query Planner.
All right, one more thing.
I know this wasn't on the agenda slide,
but I really wanted to show this slide
and I just really wanna highlight
that not everything we do in DocumentDB
is an explicit feature.
There are a lot of things that we do
behind the scenes just
to make things better.
And I wanna show you
something that's actually
what our engineers see.
It's a very chaotic graph,
but this actually represents
all the time someone...
Our customers do when
they do a switchover.
So if you're not familiar with switchover,
this is when you're running
a cluster across two different regions
and you wanna promote one over the other.
Between August 4th and
August 11th on this graph,
before we actually
introduced a optimization,
the P90 time to do a completed
switchover was 300 seconds.
We actually rolled out a
change starting August 11th
and we finished our
deployment where we simplified
the workflow,
the promotion workflow behind the scenes.
And we actually found that our P99
can go as low as 30 seconds.
Our P90 is low as 30 seconds.
So this is a 90% increase over switchover.
So this is just...
There are a lot of things that we do
as a part of our service...
Part of our service that
just makes things better.
So this is something I really
want to show you all there.
Okay, summary recap.
There's a lot of things
that we launched this year.
You know this, this recording...
I think this, this recording
will be available on YouTube later,
hence it's being recorded in the back.
So if you missed anything,
you can always come back.
You can always check out our what's new
or our release notes pages,
which has every single thing
that we've launched this year as well.
One thing I like to call out,
you may have seen some
folks wearing this hoodie.
I think the expo is just about
to open tonight or tomorrow.
If you go to the database booth,
remember that thing I talked about
that was really important
about serverless databases?
So one thing that you can go to them is
if you go to this booth,
go to them and tell them one
interesting thing that learned
and that is, as a reminder
if you forgot about it,
is that with serverless instances,
large instances scale faster
than that of smaller ones.
So remember that.
I think that the booth is
just opening up right now
and we are one of the ones that...
One of the sessions that just follow
right before the booth opening.
So hopefully you all are
actually getting the secret there
before others do,
given that the session is on a Monday.
And with that said,
thank you so much for attending a session.
I know it's Monday, 5:30.
Again, but the last ask
I have of all of you,
and this enables Cody and I to come back
year after year is really
complete the session survey
in the mobile app.
So thank you so much and
have a great re:Invent.
(audience applauds)